so this past weekend we had the distinct
honor of joining the Secretary of
Transportation in austin texas at the
South by Southwest Interactive Festival
in order to learn that pittsburgh has
been selected as one of the seven
finalists for the Smart City challenge
now the first question is what is the
Smart City challenge so instead of me
trying to describe it to you I'm going
to show you a short video the USDOT put
out but understand this the way
transportation is now is not anything
like what it will be by 2045 in the
cities that start to advance the ability
to change transportation will be the
ones that will be in the lead not only
in creating more effective inefficient
in equitable routes of transportation
and modes of transportation but they
will be the ones that will lead in the
industry and help to change an economy
so if we could show that video
for the Smart City challenge imagine a
city where transportation just works
gridlock is a thing of the past lights
turn green as you approach traffic flows
smoothly as your car talks to other cars
to avoid crashes it even talks to
pedestrians and bicyclists your
driverless taxi shows up just as your
train pulls into the station you arrive
home from work and your automated
grocery list is delivered just in time
for dinner from the farm to your table
smart it's what our cities should be
equipped with technologies that
transform our vehicles and
infrastructure so that we can safely
manage every aspect of our
transportation system what
transportation technologies should a
smart city have our goal is for you to
determine the possible so we can move
beyond traffic join the challenge
so in the next 10 weeks we have to take
this proposal and I'll go through a
little bit of what it means but it's
going to be more than you can basically
report because there's a lot of
different parts to it but it basically
breaks down into four areas it's the
modes of transportation in the way that
we're able to provide them the
technology and how it can become greater
the ability to overlay transportation
with new energy options and an open
platform so that the information that we
create can be shared to not only change
Pittsburgh but to change the world you
can get that first line
you're not working
for this gridlock the as your car talks
to other cars to avoid crashes it even
talks to pedestrians and what yep thanks
so if you look at what we want to get to
and that's the top part of it a vision
zero a safety system for all of our
transportation firm for our streets
where there are no casualties where
people aren't killed walking down the
street riding a bike driving a car a
reduction in the emissions of fifty
percent by 2030 in corridors of
opportunity creating different areas of
the city that have been part of
Pittsburgh's history part of
Pittsburgh's basically the way that the
city has been growing and developed for
centuries in creating more opportunities
for mobility for all of our residents
now I'll think about really mobility in
the previous century Andrew Carnegie in
his time it was really about how do we
get big steel to market and so we build
out rails when we build out rivers and
we build out transportation networks and
then around the 1950s and Mayor David
Lawrence we started thinking about how
do we get people downtown so that we
could become a corporate work center and
we did win 1970s or the third largest
corporate center in the United States
between New York Chicago and then
Pittsburgh but really that was all about
the automobile and we built roads for
the automobile and parking garages for
the automobile and we built tunnels and
bridges and we saw a city hollow out and
we saw what was left decline and sprawl
all around now is we're rebuilding
cities and people are moving into cities
all over the world what are the options
for a 21st century city and what can we
how can we utilize technology and other
factors in order to be able to help us
to get there so when we look
specifically at Pittsburgh we're looking
at an infrastructure that is both at the
same time antiquated but the opportunity
to create a new model where cities
around the world could follow we look at
areas of the North Shore and where a
district energy plan is already in
formation you might have seen the power
plant that's dover by PNC Park uses
steam in order to be able to heat
buildings over the North Shore we're
working to create a cogeneration of both
steam and gas in order to create get
heat and electricity and to be able to
connect the tea into a program of
interconnectivity to downtown in
downtown pack that a smokestack is
you're looking at it from pnc park again
as a steam-powered plant but has the
ability to create an entire energy
system for all of downtown on top of
that we want to create a Complete
Streets model for downtown that allows
all modes of transportation to be able
to effectively get around without the
friction that is there presently
creating new opportunities for
technology to be able to have smart
signalization to be able to end gridlock
in congestion and move all modes of
transportation around effectively
downtown connects out it connects along
the Ohio long the Allegheny River
through a green Boulevard plan all the
way out to the Highland Park bridge and
then eventually out to the allegheny
valley it connects along the Monongahela
with a new vision for Second Avenue in
the ability to create solar power at a
parking garage roof to be able to have
electric vehicles charged with the Sun
and be able to create electric avenue
all the way down to hazelwood 178 acres
of development that will be fueled by
renewable energy and where buildings
will be built that will use less energy
than they produce the entire Mon Valley
will be reconfigured as a renewable
center of electricity and electronic
vehicles down through the heart of it
the new brt system to take you from
downtown to oakland in a fast and
efficient way
with stops in uptown and Soho to see the
neighborhood become redeveloped in an
eco innovation district that will help
to be able to create the sustainability
standards that we're looking at and then
connecting down into Hazelwood right to
here in Carnegie Mellon's campus and the
opportunity for autonomous electric
vehicles to run people back and forth
with a public transit system to serve
the people of Hazelwood to opportunities
in Oakland and new economy opportunities
that will then connect over to the bus
way in connecting Homewood in east
liberty to lawrenceville Hazelwood
downtown in all of these systems being
interconnected in all of them using the
sensor technology that we saw in the
video so that in the future vehicles
will join caravans and the caravans will
run through corridors in the corridor
signalization between the sensor that's
already in the car today combined with
the sensors that will be in the public
infrastructure will create more
efficient ways from people to get from
one place to another and all of that
being developed in Pittsburgh doesn't
happen through city government it
happens with the city government that is
able to reach out and find partners in
many partners in order to be able to put
together a plan where everyone has a
part and all of the parts fit like
pieces of a puzzle and that's why we're
here today at carnegie mellon because
unlike the other cities and think about
this for a second Austin Portland San
Francisco Kansas City Denver Columbus
what does the last time you heard
Pittsburgh in that same category these
are all the boom cities of the United
States the ones that are seeing record
growth what makes Pittsburgh story is
different is we haven't seen growth in
50 years and now we're going to start to
see it and as we plan and build for it
we're going to have a transportation
network that is a part of a 21st century
and that will lead
the world and it's because of these
partners because of what we have right
here to be able to pull all of this
together which those other cities just
don't have and one of those partners is
the man standing next to me Raj has been
instrumental in putting this together in
putting together our application of
helping us through the technical
assistance of being a visionary who not
only sees it it's already doing it and
somebody who I consider a friend thanks
a lot yeah thanks a lot da mayor it's my
pleasure toad we standing here in front
of you to express my admiration and
appreciation for the mission leadership
and determination passion of the mayor
of Pittsburgh in leading this proposal
putting forth a very complete and
comprehensive mission for the future of
Transportation in Pittsburgh and we
believe that these smart city
technologies that the mayor outline very
articulately can actually make
Pittsburgh not just one of the smartest
cities in the country but one of the
smarter cities in the world so I really
want a clear command the mayor and his
team actually in pulling to this
proposal in record time in a matter of
weeks and some of his staff members are
here then the extra dishes to make it
happen on time secondly I would express
my gratitude to another local missionary
by the name of Henry Hillman who
actually runs the Hillman foundation
among other things mr. Hillman had this
vision back in 2009 to basically launch
an initiative at Carnegie Mellon called
traffic 21 basically to identify develop
and implement technologies to improve
the situation of traffic congestion that
we actually have inputs work were really
constrained by our or topology rivers
and tunnels and kohls that we feel even
if you wanted to build new lanes we
have the space to build lanes so mr.
hillman's philanthropy vision in 2009 to
launch traffic 21 that resulted in us
actually forming university
transportation center sponsored by the
u.s. department of transportation which
has then subsequently become a national
university transportation center on
safety the only such national unity
transportation center working on safety
in the country sponsored by the u.s.
department transportation so I inputs
work thanks to a civic leadership or
thanks to philanthropic leadership and
thanks to all my colleagues at Carnegie
Mellon for their technology leadership I
think we are able to basically put forth
a comprehensive plan to make Pittsburgh
a smart city or the next few weeks will
submit the full proposal in cooperation
with the mayor and this team we look
forward to a good news of course but
whether we win the final award or not we
hope to but even if you do not this
march does not stop here we will
continue this March and then continue to
make things happen support from the city
the state that the feds and various
forms and we actually ever had
significant the outreach from cities and
countries around the world asking for
hey what are you doing so well what can
we learn from here so this is only the
one of the first steps of a long journey
we have come far but we are long way to
go but this is a good progress of pat
forward so at this point let me take the
mayor and thanks and go back to the
slide was just able to take a peek at
that as well as we talk I have to also
mention the partnership that we've
created last year in an historic
memorandum of understanding with the
Department of Energy part of this in the
energy plan that's a component of the
transportation plan is built off of that
in the work that we're doing with the
University of Pittsburgh as well so this
is really pulling together all of the
city's talent to be able to do an all
hands on approach if we are selected
we will receive 40 million dollars from
the Department of Transportation to
begin all of these different projects we
will receive 10 million dollars from
Vulcan which is Paul Allen's company
there will be an additional million from
amazon as well as several million more
from other in kind services of companies
that 50 to 60 million dollars I consider
match funds I will go out and we will go
out to foundations and corporations and
others that want to be part of each of
these different developments and
challenge them to match the dollars that
will be receiving and through the course
of a decade we'll see the city transform
don't have a price tag yet we we
received I brought back from austin well
I didn't literally bring back but we've
received one hundred thousand dollars to
be able to hire consultants to help us
to figure that out but it's very much
like what we did with the summer of
learn and earn we created the model
first and then found the funding so we
aren't being limited in creating a
fifty-million-dollar plan we're creating
a vision for this city of where it needs
to go for 21st century smart
transportation and then we're going to
do it getting this and winning this will
take us there much faster but we're
still going to do it regardless but
we're win this let me be very clear
about that ten weeks well the win so
there's a couple things number one we
have to be different than seven other
cities there are six other cities we
have to be able to provide something
that they're not I think that there are
components of our plan that are
different number one we don't just look
at transportation we look at
transportation and energy number two
they want to see ways that
sustainability is a factor we have that
baked right in we're also creating
what's called an open platform so the
information that's created from this
will be able to be shared in cities
around the country which would be a
benefit to do tea and forth we have the
technology because of the talent we have
in this city to be the leaders and it's
already there but there's other programs
to that we want to see because we want
to see this help all of Pittsburgh so we
want to create an education program we
want to follow what Baltimore did with
rec to tech meaning taking our rec
centers and turning them into
after-school technical training programs
for kids so the kids that don't have an
opportunity in this new economy will
start at a very young age in Pittsburgh
and putting it in our most needed
communities
first and then we want a partner with
the Energy Innovation Center and with
community college of allegheny county
and start to train the workers who are
going to be putting these sensors all
throughout the city to have the first
crack at the jobs that then will be a
part of a new economy as well so I think
that when other cities are doing their
proposals and what I've heard from the
other mayor's was very similar I think
what Pittsburgh can do is show something
very different
so there are multiple kinds of sensors
we will make the road infrastructure
smarter that is a deployment in east
liberty and shady side as of now we're
50 traffic lights have been instrumented
with sensors each a traffic light fee
well actually watches 4q build up along
each direction to the intersection if
there's a queue starts building up it
tries to rapidly switch to a green light
in that direction so that that cube
build up actually dissipates very
quickly and so there's a project called
smooth scalable urban traffic sir track
are led by Professor rusty smith that
robotics Institute and they have already
seen from this deployment the East
Liberty deployment with 11 traffic
lights has been up and running for more
than two years now they've already seen
significant improvements in throughput
about twenty-five percent improvements
in throughput through the intersections
that translates to reduce delays and
more importantly perhaps about twenty
five percent reduction in pollution
because vehicles are moving through
faster than likely spewing up less field
that's number one number two as the
video pointed out vehicle center of the
future that we will deploy will be
connected each week we'll be able to
broadcast its location its speed towards
other vehicles to the traffic lights to
the traffic signs and so on and you can
also talk to the cloud and that for that
would be mobility data centers that we
will create as part of this project
which will collect all this information
know where the traffic hot spots are and
then maybe feedback information or to
people in cars saying that hey maybe you
should take a different route right and
if and when an accident happens or
there's basically a water line breakage
think of forbes avenue m you basically
be given direct customized you're
rerouting information for you to get to
your destination faster that second
third be acne you are plan to deploy
some autonomous vehicle technologies as
well autonomous vehicles obviously have
a ton of sensors built in them and they
will be actually talked to the
infrastructure as well so it will be
actually a connected autonomous way
and for what we would like to do as part
of the project as deploy a family of
smartphone apps that each citizen would
be able to download and customize to
their own individual needs so depending
upon where you want to go depending of
the time of day depending upon the
current traffic environment current
incidents on the roads and such you'd be
able to obtain a specific information to
get to your destination faster and then
plan ahead for your personal needs for
your family's needs and we imagine that
or over time this family of apps
electric will grow there'll be new apps
added and all of these this family of
smart Pittsburgh apps will be built on
an open platform so over time other
cities we hope likely adopt of the smart
Pittsburgh technologies and then because
we are not tied in to any particular
vendor resistance or option of our open
technology will be very minimal and they
expect that bitch work will not only
become a smart city the technologies and
then the expertise will actually go to
multiple other cities around the country
and to the world just say one thing
because I know somebody will say yeah
you should just build a subway to
Oakland so that would cost about three
three-and-a-half billion dollars so
you're not going to be able to do that
50 million they'd say well you should
just take out the signals and make it
easier for people to drive into town
build some more parking garages well we
would not only not be a finalist would
be laughed at there are very strict
guidelines of what deities looking in
deities competing against other
transportation systems around the world
and this is where the world is going the
world isn't going back it isn't going
back to build more highways it's not
going back to widen highways it's going
to find ways for people to get to places
smarter more efficiently more
effectively more equitably so that it
helps everyone and that is the challenge
in like I said before this 50 million
this is to me is the beginning of where
else we're going to be looking to spend
in the partnerships that we create are
going to be partnerships that will build
companies in Pittsburgh and the
opportunity to educate and train young
people from every neighborhood of
Pittsburgh is the opportunity for them
to have a chance in this new economy
this has a lot more to do than just
getting cars to move better throughout a
city it's how you transform a city and
for those that say driverless cars will
never happen well I'm sorry to tell you
they're already happening in Oakland
kenichi melons already driving them
throughout this city Uber's already has
the prototypes on the streets and we're
building a test track for them which is
actually a simulated city down in
hazelwood and within the next few years
you're going to see them coming around a
lot more within the next decade you're
going to be riding in them that's where
this world is going and the question is
will Pittsburgh be a leader that's the
only question
austin texas is the fastest growing city
in the united states has been for the
past four years will be for the
foreseeable future the others that held
that title Portland San Francisco Denver
they're all the ones we're competing
against people looked at that list and
they saw Pittsburgh on it and they
wondered why we're going to prove why
you not only that we're going to have a
new moniker not the smoky city the smart
city and I think that is a selling point
to all these companies that are looking
to invest in this program to be a part
of actually seeing something monumental
take pace not just another boomtown
getting another thing
ok
you